it had to be confusing going out with
guys because you're introduced the guys
who are really in the fast lane they're
the best-looking guys in the world you
meet these actors who are super handsome
you probably needed to date someone to
look like me you know who would have
appreciated it but these guys they're
like top of the food chain dudes when
you start to date am I correct
you don't other people would consider at
that yeah it's weird and then you never
know as a young kid who's famous and
wealthy but also as then you start going
up and seeing that some people it
becomes very incestual place mmm I was
like I want to date a guy that's it a
businessman
does it have Instagram doesn't have
social media right and it's completely
off the grid
in terms of that kind of stuff you dated
famous guys though right you went
through that phase yeah
wilmer he was your first guy Wilmer
Valderrama that guy you know it's hard
to have a serious relationship with he's
so [ __ ] good-looking he's gonna he's
a good guy he is a good guy he seemed
like a real nice guy Jamie Lee Curtis
was kind to you in your career you can
call her up and say listen I'm in
trouble or I'm you we just check in yeah
oh no kidding that's nice yeah I was
always wondering could you make any
really close friends and show business
or is everyone just like what did your
last movie do and that's how we evaluate
the relation we keep in touch didn't she
tell you to get rid of all the hangers
on wasn't that like when you guys do
britches right she's right cuz I you
know sometimes you just signed up having
people around when you're younger in
this industry just to have people there
cuz we're always around people and then
it could can get very lonely
were you lonely even though you were
surrounded by people yeah I think so
right because they all the other people
didn't realize that I didn't want to go
out all the time I don't want to be seen
all the time but it was like the only
time I did want to was when they were
around right
a real friend now you have good friends
now yeah what I don't I don't like to go
out is that really true
yeah I'm a homebody is it because going
out got you into trouble with the
paparazzi got you [ __ ] up your life
because I've always been like an
introvert it likes to be home
people at home but that's completely
opposite of the image we have probably
because those would have been my college
years and I would have had a whole
different experience of it and a camera
wouldn't have been there oh you so right
yeah those were your college years yeah
where you would have been out drinking
and partying but nobody would have given
it right yeah yeah yeah you're
absolutely right but my mom went out
she's like those were kind of your
colleges and then you get that she said
that's why I told you to move home